alors eric dupond moretti est il un bon
choix pour la justice c'est la question
de notre face à face ce soir et pour en
parler nous sommes avec david guiraud
porte-parole jeunesse de la france
insoumise bonsoir david guiraud merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés julien
odoul membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national bonsoir à vous
aussi
julien odoul alors eric dupond moretti
qui disait qu'il n'accepterait jamais le
poste de ministre de la justice
qu'est ce qui l'a fait changer d'avis
selon-vous emmanuel macron par exemple
qui a su convaincre je viens au 12 je
sais pas ce qui a fait changer d'avis un
monsieur dupont moretti qui dernièrement
oui manifesté toute sa répulsion pour ce
ministère et pour la politique en
général
mais plus généralement moi ce qui
m'inquiète sur ce choix c'est que ça
dénote finalement la vision de la
justice des manades macron mêmes macron
choisi un ministre qui est un militant
d'extrême gauche et qui était un
militant d'extrême gauche qui a une
vision de la justice totalement partial
et je dirais antidémocratique
je rappellerai que monsieur dupont
moretti il ya quelques années en 2015
donc disais qu'il fallait interdire le
front national interdire donc le premier
parti d'opposition interdire 11 millions
de français donc qui pensent que marine
le pen serait la plus à même de diriger
notre pays
je trouve ça extrêmement graves comme
signal de désigner cette personne donc
comme ministre de la justice et
responsable donc de l'impartialité de
l'état de droit
en tout cas en plus il yad autres
évidemment d'autres état de fait qui ont
jalonné la carrière et du moins les
dernières années notamment sa
fascination pour la défense d'abdelkader
meira donc il est très très fiers de
défendre donc abdelkader meira la façon
dont il a traité d
candia gelé soutien des familles des
victimes juives de l'attentât de
toulouse en les traitant d'extrémistes
juifs qui se foutait le bordel enfin
voilà du pot eric dupond moretti
c'est ça c'est de la violence verbale
c'est comment dirais-je c'est une
personnalité extrêmement clivante
on le voit d'ailleurs avec un stand de
réactions hostiles de la part des
magistrats et surtout voilà c'est
surtout une justice extrêmement laxiste
au sien puisque c'est dans la continuité
de madame belloubet un jeu direct
eric dupond-moretti va creuser encore la
tombe de la justice que ce choix avec le
retour des jihadistes français que ce
soit avec la libération datant de
traiter tous les thèmes du débat
on sent une âme à l'elysée y en a
beaucoup en l1 je sais mon secteur oui
d'alors david biraud il ya eu plusieurs
idées véhiculées effectivement par
julien houde où l'on va tenter de les
prendre dans l'ordre ont effectivement
voilà et il a été accusé eric dupond
moretti
dès sa nomination par marine le pen 1 du
rassemblement national auquel appartient
julien odoul de militants d'extrême
gauche qui veulent intervenir le rn déjà
sur ce point est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce diagnostic vous on est
plus pour interdire le rassemblement
national dont on disait qu'il ya une
époque où il fallait l'interdire ou ces
gens étaient des anciens putschistes des
anciens de l'oas organisation armée
secrète qui voulait renverser le général
de gaulle d'ailleurs ça me fait rire que
marine le pen aille il lui rendre
hommage alors que les gens qui ont fondé
le front national était affilié à des
anciens nazis
bon mais sur sur dupond moretti
bon en ce moment on parle que de lui
mais parce qu'on ne voit que lui parce
qu'il ya que lui avoir dans ce
remaniement faut commencer par dire ça
faut pas tomber aussi dans ce piège là
on nous annonce et je vous rappelle des
corps aux prises à droite des grosses
prises à gauche des gens qui pèse dans
le milieu institutionnel au final dupont
moretti bas on voit que lui parce que
c'est une sorte de cactus dans le dans
le désert moi quand je vois par exemple
que darmanin et schiappa qui entre au
ministère de l'intérieur pour moi c'est
le début d'une blague c'est pas un
remaniement mais bon sur dupond moretti
je pense que ces gens n'ont pas les
épaules pour ses ministères là et que
c'est dur au kasaï sur dupond-moretti
nous on l'a eu en procès contre nous
contre la france on mise donc évidemment
qu'on va demander des garanties
maintenant j'estime que de toute façon
au niveau du ministère de la justice
pour nous pour la france est soumise en
termes de traitement politique des
opposants ça peut être difficilement
pire que madame b to b
donc moi je rejoins par le syndicat de
la magistrature qui en est à demander
des garanties des garanties par rapport
à ce qu'a fait notamment monsieur dupont
moretti en tant qu'avocat qui deviennent
pas interférer dans son rôle de ministre
de la 8e' de la justice et ensuite il ya
aussi le programme qu'il a annoncé que
j'ai écouté moi j'ai écouté son discours
je pense que dans son discours il donne
raison à énormément de choses qu'on
disait à la france soumise d'ailleurs
nous n'étions pas la seule organisation
politique a parlé de ça mais parions sur
l'indépendance de la justice la réforme
du parquet ça fait des années qu'on le
demande parce qu'on sait que les
procureurs sont souvent à charge nous on
a eu un procureur des procureurs sur le
dos à la france a soumises de manière
totalement disproportionnée donc qu'il
avance sur l'indépendance de la justice
ça serait une bonne chose au sein d'un
gouvernement notamment de b2b et de ses
équipes qui sont radicalement contre ça
que les enquêtes préliminaires ne soit
pas éternel comme on l'a vu à la france
à smith très récemment
c'est aussi une de nos préoccupations on
espère qu'il va avancer sur ça que le
secret de l'enquète soit respecté ça
c'est une chose à laquelle on tient en
ce moment on est en déclin dans un pays
où le secret de l'enquète n'existe plus
c'est à dire que toujours sa fuite dans
les journaux et les gens n'ont plus
droit à la dignité au respect ça c'est
quelque chose sur lesquels j'attends
monsieur dupont moretti
doute je viens on va vous redonner la
parole bien sûr david guiraud julian
d'où vous qu'est ce qui vous fait le
plus peur parce que vous avez cités
effectivement voilà beaucoup d'arguments
contre lui qu'est ce qui vous fait le
plus peur avec ce nouveau garde des
sceaux aux airelles ce qui est à
craindre ces deux d'avoir une justice
encore plus politisé qu'elle ne l'était
avant avec mme belloubet et les craintes
doivent être partagés par tous les
partis d'opposition et je partage
également le besoin de garanties de la
france insoumise puisque la france
insoumise aussi a subi les foudres
judiciaires on voit bien qu'on a un
pouvoir qui instrumentalise la justice
comme un bras armé pour taper ces
oppositions pour à chaque fois qu'il y
en a une qui devient un peu trop
menaçante et inquiétante bad actionner
ce levier là pour essayer de les faire
fléchir tout ça évidemment avec monsieur
dupont moretti avec ses récentes
déclarations
avec son son militantisme anti rn
assumer affirmé et légalement et
évidemment nous fait craindre le pire
ce qui me fait craindre aussi c'est sa
déclaration tout à l'heure donc lors de
la passation de pouvoir de dire que son
ministère sera celui de l'antiracisme
mais on aurait préféré qu'il nous dise
que son ministère sera celui de la fin
du laxisme sera celui du rétablissement
tout cas la protection de toutes les
libertés des français sera celui de
l'impunité pour les criminels et
délinquants c'est ça son rôle mais être
le ministère de l'antiracisme
l'antiraciste qui aujourd'hui est devenu
un véritable racisme ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il va nommer à sa traoré
comme pour paroles ou directrice de
cabinet qu'elle est calé ce signal en
fait c'est donner un gage encore une
fois aux militants racialiste à tous les
déconstructeurs à tous ceux qui ces
dernières semaines ont fait tant de mal
que ce soit à nos policiers qui auraient
cédé boulonné nos statuts etc tout ça
évidemment c'est un très mauvais signal
et je constate qu'il est dans la
véritablement dans la dans l'autoroute
qui a été un tracé par nicole belloubet
qui a fait beaucoup de mal à la
magistrature qui a fait beaucoup de mal
aux avocats qui étaient dans la rue
avant la crise sanitaire
tu avais viraux je vois
la continuité je vous vois lever les
yeux au ciel effectivement temps on
aligne et julien odoul parlais tout à
l'heure où la de la défense du frère de
mohamed merah c'est en 2017 par maître
dupond-moretti c'est le procès le plus
difficile de ma carrière on a dit que
j'étais c'était la honte de la
profession on a menacé mes enfants mais
ça a été pour moi un honneur de le
défendre
ça vous inspire quoi vous à la france
insoumis ce genre de déclaration
rappelle mohamed merah qui a tué des
enfants juifs dans une cour d'école
ça vous inspire quoi le problème c'est
pas que monsieur meira soient défendus
moi je pense que c'est leur honneur
c'est pas qu'il soit défendu le problème
c'est le l'essence même du métier
d'avocat mais qui disent c'est un
honneur mais moi je ne suis pas l'avocat
de monsieur dupont moretti
tout le monde a droit d'être défendu
maintenant ce qui pose problème c'est
les déclarations et les défenses
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que vous avez
vu des aussi des associations notamment
aux féministes qui sont montés au
créneau parce que le poids ne sais pas
qui le défendent en soit c'est les
déclarations qu'il a pu avoir
ou son comportement qui peut être
questionné c'est quand même autre chose
mais voilà mais sinon franchement faut
pas être médium quoi c'est pas dire
qu'on veut être un ministre de la
justice anti raciste c'est quoi la
solution sinon faut être un ministre de
la justice raciste non en bon bah alors
c'est pas ça la déclaration qui devrait
tous nous inquiéter c'est le fond des
récentes qu'ils entendent ce qu'ils
disent presque doublé en un an et demi
de mener des réformes de fond moi c'est
ça qui m'intéresse en tant que militant
politique je vais pas m'arrêter à une
déclaration qui pour l'instant n'engage
que lui le respect du secret de
l'enquêté
l'indépendance de la justice et
d'indépendance réelle la séparation du
parquet et du siège que que les
conditions de vie en en détention soit
améliorée parce que effectivement
aujourd'hui ça ça il a raison les
conditions de vie sont indignes dans de
nombreuses prisons aujourd'hui voilà ça
c'est des vrais chose en finir avec la
surpopulation carcérale qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des gens qu'on ne met pas dans les
prisons c'est aussi une vraie question
qui se pose pour beaucoup de nos nos
concitoyens c'est normal d'avoir ces
débats c'est sain d'avoir ces débats
mais je veux dire moi je vais pas suivre
l'extrême droite sur un débat de mots
voilà moi je moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est le front regardez par exemple en
ce moment l'inspection générale de la
justice enquête sur le parquet national
financier suite
vous savez à la sphère des fans est
c'est à dire des gens qui ont été mis
sous écoute pendant la sphère fillon
sarkozy je sais plus
proche je pense que c'est un énorme
problème ce qu'il s'est passé mais
saisir l'inspection générale de la
justice c'est à dire quelque chose qui
relève du pouvoir exécutif pour enquêter
sur le pouvoir judiciaire
c'est un problème de séparation des
pouvoirs le syndicat de la magistrature
demande des garanties là dessus moi
aussi
sur l'un des ponts sur les remontées
d'informations savait que la remontée
d'informations en ce moment c'est la
remontée d'information du pouvoir
judiciaire vers des gens qui sont
affiliés au pouvoir exécutif ça c'est
une vraie question
parlons des débattront soyons exigeants
sur les débats de fond intraitable mais
les questions vraiment accessoire de
dire moi je serais un ministre
antiraciste franchement c'est ça le
débat
merci david guiraud merci également
julien au double en tout cas pour ce
face à face en direct sur arte france
merci à vous deux